the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so this is a as I understand it
continuing the conversation you already
started on education and this is sort of
the last of the I think education
lectures where so the sort of what what
I propose to do today is to just kind of
try to tell a story a single story that
kind of fits is fits some of the facts
together you've seen some of the broad
patterns of so dysfunctionality already
as well as some of the kind of local
success stories if you like I think the
last lecture was about this NGO prathab
and its many efforts to improve
education so what I'm going to do today
is is kind of continue from there but
talk a little bit more so a big-picture
focusing mostly on on so the goal is to
tie things together into a story that
might make some sense and help us think
forward about if so if this is what's
going on where should we act that's
always the ultimate question we have in
mind which is to try to find the way to
an action point or a lever and it's only
by wrapping in these facts into ass
narrative that we can kind of find a
lever so what I want to do is I want to
go from the facts to a lever and we will
go there is by talking about a specific
interpretation of the facts so that
that's what I won't want to do and I'm
hoping that you know you've already kind
of read some of this material and I'm
sufficiently engaged with it that you
know we'll have a lot of discussion
along the way about is this a reasonable
interpretation of the facts or not
and I'm I'm very much open to the idea
that you may think that this is not the
right interpretation and we can
definitely you should feel free to
propose alternatives or wherever you
think it's you know it's you think I'm
going too fast or trying to trying to
sort of push the logic too far
you should stop me or if you a question
so I I think that the first fact which
is sort of I think very very widely
accepted but somehow not necessarily
very widely documented is that education
is actually beneficial for the people
who get it and this this is a this is
you would imagine that this is something
that we would have seen tons and tons of
edges of reliable Auk evidence on but in
fact the reliable evidence even on this
very basic question is relatively weak
the reason why education evidence tends
to be weak is a you know as you know
when you don't it's not education is not
like taking a medicine so I think I did
the nice thing I'll take a medicine is
that I take a medicine a week later I'm
better education something that has
action at a distance it's like something
that you know I get educated today and
tomorrow and day after the day after
that and and then some distant future I
get a job and that's what it benefits me
so that that sort of that that
remoteness of it is actually that
remoteness of is actually part of the
reason why it's hard to find evidence
for good evidence for education is that
you know you need to have a data set
where you need you saw who got educated
today and what happened to their salary
is 20 years later and that's not always
easy to find for obvious reasons you
might imagine that you really need to
track people in some way so that's why
there's not much evidence
the evidence that there is a significant
part of it comes from from countries
like the US where the evidence is very
clear education seems to have a clear
and relatively high stable rate of
return hasn't changed very much over
time and a few studies like the one from
Indonesia which also find the same thing
and actually find surprisingly
relatively similar rates of return on
education and the benefits of education
in Indonesia seem to be similar to that
in the US and that's something that when
it came out was rather surprising to
people why why would we be surprising
what would you have expected
right so you could imagine that it would
be education in the US as higher quality
so maybe it's it would be higher the
Ritter's we hire the u.s. anybody want
to suggest a reason for the opposite
yeah next excellent point but primary
education is what we're talking about
right now so that's not that expensive
right it's mostly free
absolutely the opposite view is that
education is scarce in the u.s. in
Indonesia and relative especially in the
early 70s very few people had the had
primary education so you might imagine
that something that scarce typically has
a higher price so you might imagine that
it would be more rewarded so you could
have imagined it going either way turns
out these two effects seem to have
canceled out canceled out and you get on
net roughly the same return on education
in in the u.s. as you get in Indonesia
but this that's all that to say that we
we seem to think that there is a can of
these things it's not that there's a
huge amount of evidence but whatever
there is seems pretty consistent and
compelling so I I think most people
accept the idea that there is a benefit
from education now that's and then the
next the next question that then arises
is if there is a benefit from education
why are people getting you know such
lousy quality you know if it is the case
that why isn't it the case that the
education systems kind of stand up and
deliver and and you get get what if
education is valuable why isn't there a
system that supplies it why is it that
you know you have all the schools where
kids are going and learning nothing yeah
for the investment or the governance the
case maybe and apparently
disappearing the other thing that unlike
other investments the returns like we
talked about earlier are very so you're
saying that one reason why education
might be different is people don't the
connection between the cost you are
paying and the returns you're getting is
weak so maybe the government I don't
really think about the the returns the
government wants me to send my children
to school so I send them but I don't
really think about it so I don't think
about the returns I don't make the
investments in it I don't really care
about it
it's just something the government wants
me to do and therefore I don't get
benefits so that would be I'm going to
try to suggest evidence that that's not
what's going on but that's exactly right
that's one very plausible hypothesis is
that you know this is something that
people really they're not getting it
buying education like they buy you know
machines they're getting education from
the government as a kind of a gift and
therefore they don't care about it so
that's one kind of explanation but
that's exactly right there's one one
possibility let's keep going a bit and
welcome yeah no go ahead
MARY POPPINS look at that like secondary
education or university education is
actually
alternative you which we'll come back to
and spend some time on is that people
actually don't be it's not that people
don't believe education is valuable but
they don't know which part of education
is valuable and that's sort of what what
you're suggesting yeah
so the idea that you know poor quality
education
right so I think we that sort of goes
back to the conversation we had a little
while ago which is that we would imagine
that in Indonesia education would be a
lot more valuable than its in the in the
u.s. because there's so much less of it
and you would think that you know when
I'm the first primarily educated person
in the in the village that's much more
valuable than being the two thousand
nevertheless we don't find high returns
in Indonesia we find comparable to the
u.s. so the idea is implicitly that the
returns to education are low in
Indonesia
partly because the quality is that's
actually some somebody suggested exactly
that which is that one reason why you
might expect lower returns and in
Indonesia is that the quality is lower
and so I think the concern is education
is socially valuable we want it because
you know it is the you know education
there's not much many educated people on
the other hand maybe the delivery
systems are weak and therefore it's not
worth getting it so that's all that's a
trade-off and the question if you look
at the other evidence you already looked
at it it seems like it's hard to imagine
somebody who's in fifth grade and can't
really read having got much benefit from
education so our presumption is that at
least a significant proportion of the
people who are getting the fifth grade
without being able to read are not
getting anything out of the education
they're just going through the motions
so why is it that there are so many
people who are going through the motions
rather than saying look why am I wasting
my time with this education thing unless
it's worth something to me that's sort
of the question and that a corollary to
that question comes from the fact that
in in fact the the program experience
suggests is it not even that hard to
improve quality it may well be that you
know you could imagine that it's just
impossible to improve quality because
you know kids are very difficult to
teach well if my kids are not difficult
to teach the whole process
audience is that whenever you have an
intervention which sort of provides them
with some extra little bit of extra help
and some some focused help on what they
need the kids improve fast so that makes
it even more puzzling because you know
at some level it's easy to improve them
the kids education if you've got a high
quality education that has value so
what's going on why where's the pipeline
broken that's yeah
ya know I think that is part we could
come and try and try to in a sense
develop that hypothesis and look at why
how that can help us explain a whole
bunch of different things so that's
exactly the kind of hypothesis that will
come come - and it's it's good that we
already start hinting at it but it's I
just want to first frame the question
quite sharply there seems like education
is something that prime of se is
valuable and it's not hard to deliver
those two things have used what you've
seen you've seen that it seems valuable
it seems very low quality so many people
aren't getting anything out of it and
it's easy to make sure that they get
something out of it those three facts
how are they sitting together that's
that's the question you know you would
think that something is one of these
facts has to give that's that's the
puzzle why is it that this thing that's
easy to improve is not being improved
even though improvements will generate
large gains
that's another possibility now part of
the reason we emphasize some of the
program experience was a large is a
relative word but presume operates on a
fairly like a state in India the stated
in is of the you know it's often larger
than in any five countries you want
randomly named in the world so it's not
small in any obvious scale of small
that's why we were emphasizing it so if
you take your five countries at random
this some of those tested where they
were car would be smaller than that the
states in this because India so many
people okay so I this is sort of the
story that several of you have already
hinted at which is that a story that
parents parents have the wrong view of
which part of education is valuable so
starting point of that is we call it an
illusory s-shape so I you know the idea
of an s-shape right yes the idea of an
s-shape is that you know when you get a
little bit of Education that has very
little value and then as I get more and
more education the value of the
education I'm getting keeps goes up for
a while and then at some point
presumably it flattens off once you got
your PhD presumably it doesn't you know
the second PhD isn't worth that much at
least in income terms so at some point
it's gonna flatten off so the returns go
kind of like that then like that and
then like that that's an S is that clear
why it's an S okay so that that idea so
parents seem one of the hypotheses that
I think we've been most persuaded by and
is that parents seem to believe that you
know there is a real jackpot if you
get to the end of the education tunnel
so they think of education as being this
tunnel once you get into the tunnel
there's nothing good happening for a
long time when you come out of the
tunnel those who managed to come out of
the tunnel which means you get through
the whole school system you graduate
from school from high school then you
get a government job automatically
that's that's how they describe it 70
percent of them think that if my child
could only get to high school he would
actually get a government job fact the
probability that he would actually get a
government job is less than half of that
so they seem to at the top end they seem
to overvalue education they think that
you know if my child would only get
through this this whole tunnel it is
there's a job waiting for him but in
fact that's not true they're not enough
government jobs around so you don't get
these good jobs on the others on the
other end when and this is this is the
fact that's much harder to appreciate
you could find out what the probability
of getting a government job is
relatively easily was really hard to
find out this what are the benefits and
especially your pair illiterate parent
what are the benefits of getting you
know getting three years of education so
and if you think about it in the u.s.
the u.s. actually nobody gets serious of
education therefore we can't even tell
what the benefits are but I think in
what is surprising but maybe not
surprising once you think about it is
that the benefits of people who get
three years of education is
insubstantial what why are they
substantial well there's a bunch of
stuff that you that it's hard to
appreciate living from sort of when the
perspective of living in the u.s. now
but are not automatic so for example
many people don't find out about by
government programs that are available
to help them why because they don't
really read any you know newspapers or
flyers or
the TV person says something they don't
understand what is being said so even a
minimal understanding of just how the
system works actually gets you large
benefits so they're all or another
example people often give is that even
if you if you go from like first grade
to third grade and you learn to read you
can read the instructions on your back
or fertilizer your bag of fertilizer
says use one teaspoon no more you know
you have to use one teaspoon no more and
put one cup of water with it just being
able to read that has a large benefit in
a world where people certainly both over
lots of evidence of people overusing and
under using fertilizer so just the fact
that you can read the instructions on
the packet is very very has large
benefit so the reason why even getting a
third grade education has a benefit is
because there are lots of things in the
world lots of information that's
transmitted to reading for example like
what the government program is how to
properly use fertilizer what seeds new
seeds have become available
for planting and that might be in the
newspaper somebody might have taken an
ad but you don't read the ad you'll
never find out so their benefits lots of
benefits even if you can read a little
you don't have to be able to do calculus
to be able to get benefits of education
I think that's the evidence this picture
that I'm going to show you is plots kind
of actual actual and perceived returns
in Madagascar to the extent that they
can be estimated the actual returns are
pretty constant the perceived returns
come from a survey where parents will
asked what the returns were and the
perceived returns look more more concave
that is to say they're more flat at the
beginning lower returns at the beginning
at the beginning you think that you're
not going to get much returns and then
as you go up they get you know if they
cross and you think you are going to get
more returns than you actually get
yeah that's the what that is is the
percentage increase in your percentage
increase in your earnings for an extra
year of Education and you go to 11 to 12
what's your percentage increase in
earnings
so and this in some sense is actually
not this kind of these pictures sort of
gets the idea but in fact it doesn't
actually tell you how big the effect is
the reason is that in fact there are
some people who generally overestimate
the benefits for education so some
parents think education is
extraordinarily valuable and a lot of
parents think that education is
completely useless so this this this
this yellow curve with an average of
very lows and very highs and so so in
some sense the average looks actually
less wrong than the individual parents
are think so some parents are
overestimating their returns they're all
sending their children to school others
are just think education is worthless
for at least for their children and
their children is important in that
sentence a lot of people think education
something that benefits those other
children and people from rich families
can benefit from education our children
don't benefit so this is clearly a
strong kind of cell self discrimination
which you will come back to in a bit
so that average actually masks a lot of
of divergence so so what I'm going to do
now is actually kind of so guru instead
of so I'm going to take this as a
hypothesis the fact that this what I
would call elite bias the idea that it's
kind of looks like an people think it's
an s-shape returns are at the high end
no returns at the low end
assume that that's true and look at how
that can help us explain a bunch of
other facts okay so
so we're gonna look at what this does
for the parents that teaches the
students you see where we're going we're
gonna make a hypothesis we've made the
hypothesis now we're going to look at
what that hypothesis does particularly
you know a bunch of facts and we try to
fit together a bunch of those facts then
at the end I'll tell you some other
facts that you probably don't know which
also kind of fit fit this hypothesis so
it's sort of a way to you know give it a
bit more power if you like try it out on
things that you so this is the
so one implication is think of the first
first implication of this imagine that I
believe that you get benefits only if
you only if you get to high school and
you have three children and you don't
really can't really afford to put all
three of them through high school so in
truth as we saw the returns are pretty
constant so an extra year is an extra
year if if it were the case that an
extra year an extra year
how should you spend the money equally
you're going to equal since all the
children there's no reason to
discriminate why give one of them a
chance and not the others any any bias
towards equity will make you just spend
equal amounts or over the children why
because they're all you know they're all
your children
why discriminate you know one year of
education is one year of education so
there's no reason to discriminate now
think of imagine we believed something
else we believed that the first years of
education are not worth much but then
the final years are worth a lot how
would we spend our money
right you have a lot you think of it as
being I'm you're going to have a kind of
you guess which of your children will be
good at education and you're going to
give all your education to that child
and kind of give the other one nothing
that's one implication of this view is
that you're going to discriminate among
your children and you're going to now
the way you go to this command is
probably you probably don't believe your
children are identical so you look for
signs you can say you know maybe in
first grade one of the children was
doing better than the other it means
nothing
some children do well in first grades
have children too badly in first grade
many of you who were MIT we're doing
badly in first grade and then ended up
in MIT I'm sure some people were doing
very well in first grade didn't get to
MIT so it's a very poor predictor your
first grade performance a very very poor
predictor of your long-term performance
or it's a predictor but not particularly
reliable one but you know parents what
do what do they have to go on they're
going to look at which child is you know
doing well in first grade and then put
their money on that one and you so if
you would you wouldn't just probably
pick one at random when you pick one
based on some very noisy signal you'll
observe you know their you know their
whether they come back from first grade
with you know whether they they chewed
it chewed up their pencils in first
grade more or less or something and
you'll decide well this one's fit for
education this one's not and then you're
going to put your money on that but
you're going to find some way of since
you can't spend equal amounts on both
you're going to find some signal that's
allow you're going to allow you to
discriminate right that's sort of what
you'd expect
and
so that's that sir so actually let me go
let me go back one slide just talk about
discrimination before we a little bit
more before we get to this come back to
this okay
so this is something that you if you
were they do field work in developing
countries this is something that jumps
out at you and it's something that you
spend will like me I have spent all my
adult life in the u.s. so I'm kind of
used to the US norm so you go to
somebody's house what's the chance
you'll hear parent with two children one
sitting here the other standing there
and you know he looks at the child who's
sitting there and says oh you know that
one he's an idiot he's not capable of
study literally and I mean I don't mean
metaphorically I mean literally that was
the idiot that this one she's really
bright and and you hear that all the
time it's something you'll never hear in
the u.s. you'll never hear parents
actually pointing to one of the children
saying you know this one's an idiot now
that comes very much out of this theory
that in a sense there are these I have
to pick the winner the pressure on the
parents is to pick the winner because if
you don't pick the winner you wasted
your money so they're trying to pick the
winner and in a sense they in fact
trying to persuade not just the D
themselves but also the siblings to go
along with it and you here see that very
much I've also seen which is even more
touching is one child saying oh yeah you
know you ask him which school you go to
he says oh I go to the to this this
school but I don't really go anymore and
I said why and he says well you know I'm
stupid I can't do it but you know my my
brother over there he's really smart
he's going to the private school and
he's doing very well and so everybody in
the system internalized it you see that
very clear image of everybody in turn
having internalized and that's useful
for the family because the family
doesn't want to sustain you know a
feeling of inequality so if all children
believe that there's only one child
who's smart among them then it's good
for the family you don't you the harmony
in the family remains because everybody
but all the other children are willing
to not be educated because they think
they are not fit to be educated so
everybody buys into this idea
that this one child is bright you see
that where all the time just you know
primal facing you see it all the time
it's not just that you could we'll also
talk about evidence I also wanted to say
that you know that's the shape of it
it's often use here this you know people
pointing to this child and saying what
that one is an idiot and that that sort
of very striking you become the u.s. you
never hear a parent say that and I don't
think it comes out of the fact that
these are worst parents they love their
children they'll do lots for their
children but they don't believe they
really believe that there is this sort
of this they need to be very good at
picking who's who's the winner because
they need to justify that to themselves
they need to justify that them to their
other children you know the fact that
they pick the right winner that's very
important to them and you see you see
that very much so two studies one is in
Burkina Faso they found that if
conditional on my cognitive score in a
kind of us in a simple test score if my
brother is doing well I'm less likely to
be in school I was a very so if my
brother's doing well or my sister's
doing well that hurts my chances of
getting investment so that's exactly
what we're talking about picking winners
second in Colombia when they were given
a conditional cash transfer conditional
cash transfer is like some money which
you get if your child let in school and
the way you had that implemented is that
some children were eligible for it so
basically when some children were
eligible for it parents decided well
we'll invest in this child that picked
the child to invest in that meant you
stopped investing the other one the
other child actually we're less likely
later in school if your brother was
getting this you know was encouraged by
the government
Douce to go to school so the government
was actually kind of focused on one
child and you were getting some money
from sending one of the children to
school
the other one was then neglected and so
you see exactly this pattern of you know
parent strength yeah based on some age
rule I think there's only certain grades
were eligible if I remember right so it
was like seven graders can get it for
sixth graders count or something I think
that was the rule it's an age or age or
I think maybe a class
and also conditional transfer
yes both are excellent question it's I
think yes it's still true when it's free
because one of the ways you discriminate
is by sending your bright child to
private school you actually spend
resources to send it into private school
or you get him a tutor another you know
he gets special help or he doesn't have
to do the housework he gets time to do
this homework in the evening while all
the other children are like you know you
know tying up the goat or whatever
giving food to the cow or whatever else
they're doing he's the one who gets to
do the homework so that's that's one
sense in which you still have lots of
discrimination and to answer your other
question it's true that I think that the
discrimination again that's related the
answer I just gave is is also relevant
for that which is that part of the way
to operate is not just discrimination in
in money spent it's also in time it's
also in this who gets to whose job is to
tie up the cow whose job is to take care
of the younger siblings all of those get
allocated unequally so the child who
gets to go to private school typically
is also the one who doesn't take care of
the cow so you you get low loaded on
benefits from that the answer your
question okay
okay so another implication of this is
that you would sort of this is a related
point which is that pair of parents are
of will often so another implication of
this is that if people associate
education with particular forms of
getting a particular job then when there
are more of those jobs they might now
start discriminating more against this
children why because you know now there
is a valuable opportunity available for
my daughter she can get this kind of job
if she only gets this degree and I'm
going to now try to therefore find
resources to make sure my daughter can
get that degree that might mean that I'm
going to give up on my son entirely so
discrimination so you might actually
another consequence related consequence
of this is that when a particular job
appears which has high returns you you
would get higher which you perceive
generates higher returns for education
you would target money towards getting
that job and that would increase this
tendency toward discrimination so then
there's an experiment in India
whoof where very nice experiment but
what this guy did is he he you know
there are all these call centers in
India you must have dealt with one if
you've ever had a you know called United
Airlines for example it's kind of
especially you can was one of the things
I love about this is once they hear my
name their accent quickly changes
and they stopped tried to fake an
American accent I figured that I don't
care so much but so these these these
call centers you are in in this part of
North India where there is actually huge
discrimination against girls otherwise
but what it is in this experiment is
went to these villages near the call
center and said well you know there's a
call center right there and if your
chick doctor graduates high school she
can get a job there so that was the
experiment and he go went and told and
you immediately find a very parent
suddenly starting to discriminate
against their sons they start to start
to figure out you know you know my
daughter can get this good job and now I
should just put all the money in her
education and what happens to my son it
doesn't matter anymore so you get this
pattern of once parents decide that you
know there is a jackpot to be had you
know it's very easy to get into these
patterns of massive discrimination
within the family
so in particular girls education whence
went up why because all centers like
girls apparently the view way is may or
may not be true which is that girls are
easier to train to be call center
employees they're more docile more I
don't know they learn English faster
there are all kinds of theories but in
any case call centers like girls for
some unspecified reason so it was they
found out that there was a big demand
for girls the result was that you would
get you get this effect on boys or net
boys were not affected but suck when the
but parents already the best line had
said oh my this son he is not really fit
for education so those kids really
really got hurt when this happened
because they they started for all those
kids who were who the parents had
decided were not fit for education their
education actually dropped when their
sister started getting these jobs you
see you started substituting away from
their education towards less education
for them so that's this is all to say
that you know parents are actually using
all this these cues to figure out which
child to put the money on because they
believe that if you I put the money on
one child that's I'll get much bigger
benefits than sharing it across children
and then all these cues seem to matter
ok let's go back to different fact
another thing that that of course
matters is information in this world for
parents
what matters is their perceived returns
as we that's what we were talking about
we're talking about perceived returns
we're talking about the fact that
parents think the returns are high or
they are high when you get twelfth grade
education and low if you get less than
12 education etc so in Madagascar people
parents were shown this particular
picture
this picture is kind of a way to capture
the returns to education so without any
degree you get 3 kgs of grain if you get
like a few more years you get 4 you get
more you get 7 etc so this was roughly
the right scaling so this is roughly how
how the returns are in Madagascar yeah
so that's the range
for with females it goes from 34 to 163
for men from 47 to 225 so this is this
is this what this was what they were
shown when they were shown this turned
out so actually the before they did that
they actually asked parents what you
think are the returns to education you
know before they short didn't they
actually ask them you know you think
it's you know if your child got an
education how much would his income go
up by so they had written that down then
they showed them this picture and what's
nice is that the parents who who already
thought their children were going to get
high returns their behavior didn't
change very much what whose behavior has
changed the parents who thought that the
returns what the children were much
lower than they really are and about 50%
of the parents had very low returns and
for those parents you get a very
substantial improvement in no that's not
it nowhere okay so
it was a very substantial improvement in
the children's school attendance to the
point where of every intervention we
have studied they the cheapest way to
improve school attendance that we found
ever is this one you know this really
you know is an extraordinary cheap
intervention doesn't cost much money to
tell people these the returns on
education are higher than you think once
if you can do it in a credible way that
improves the education very is very
cheaply and it has a substantial effect
this turns out to be the cheapest single
thing that you know poverty actions lab
research has found for improving
education obviously it doesn't do
everything you can't go very far with
this because you know it's not going to
this still like all kinds of other
things if the education system is broken
then people are not going to learn
anything in the school etc but to get
them into school this this is a very
very cheap way to do it so there's lots
of parents who are clearly
discriminating against the children not
sending the school because they think
their children are not going to get
anything out of it why do they think
that well they think that their children
are never going to make it to the you
know to to the twelfth grade or whatever
it takes to get real money from
education so they're sort of already
assume that my child is never going to
make it to twelfth grade since he's
never going to make your child well that
was the point and therefore they don't
send children to school we persuade them
that even if you went from third grade
to fifth grade you get extra returns
then they start sending children to
school so the returns to primary
education for many many parents are
massively underestimated yeah
education
fires which taste at the regression two
people died
yeah so people have looked at that they
typically it's difficult to look at
because you could imagine that you know
very few people who wealthy families
stop at our trail but to the extent that
you can look at it you don't see big
differences
it seems mostly there's some differences
but not of the more order of magnitude
you're suggesting yeah
see how the other kids they're going too
slow look they seem to be learning
there's always complaining about it are
there any effects
nobody's looked I mean people who look
at this my problem is that when you
study peer effects the first problem is
that typically your peers are not
randomly chosen so you know you hang out
with families that are like other like
yours
so therefore the peer effects tend to be
overestimated you find you look at what
look like peer effects could be just the
effect of you know who do you hang out
with so if I ask you know people so
there's lots of evidence of peer effects
but not not so much at this level this
is hard to randomly assign peers now one
place where you can randomly assign
peers turns out to be in college so
there is a nice set of studies of like
of Dartmouth for example in Dartmouth
there's a college lottery and you get
different roommates based on your
lottery so if you get the roommates who
are more inclined to study you're more
inclined to study you get in roommates
or morning trying to drink you are more
inclined to drink there seems to be
clear evidence of some kinds of peer
effects but it's hard to find because of
this reason that but when I look at it
it's if you know that the data it looks
like this huge peer effects you look in
the US and you look at around Boston and
you'll find that in in Somerville people
who live in Somerville seem to be you
know live with other people who don't
get much funny education and people who
live in Lexington get in live with other
people who get a lot of education that's
not because of large peer effects it's
because people who want to get a large
education good education go to live in
Lexington or other characteristics of
people who go live in Lexington rich
people live in Lexington it's not
because of peer so peer effects are hard
to detect but I think they're where
people have tried to look at it like
with these Dartmouth lotteries and stuff
they find them but it's hard to detect
for the reason we just discussed okay
so now what I want to do is switch the
switch to the teacher so we we we talked
about the effect of this on on the on
the on the parents the parents do two
things one is that they don't invest in
most of the children I'll come back to
the parents actually later and the
second is that they discriminate now
let's let's go to the teachers it's same
same hypothesis teachers also believe
and maybe teachers don't intrinsically
have to believe this if parents believe
that the only goal of the school is to
get the children to 12th grade or
whatever to get through school then
teachers will have the same incentives
so the teachers will believe what the
parents believe because doesn't matter
where what the truth is I'm going to get
paid if the teachers if the parents like
me and the parents like me if I have the
belief that they have so it's not clear
that the teachers mean even need to have
the wrong beliefs but I still cysts I
suspect parents teachers do have the
wrong belief and I'll tell you why in a
little bit so first thing that that
implies is that teachers will teach to
the top of the class right you know if
you believe that the goal of this whole
thing is to get children to complete 12
grade and in addition you believe that
you know and you live in a country where
most people don't complete 12 grade then
you're going to say well most people are
not capable of completing 12 grade
because in fact that's what you see you
know only 20 percent complete twelfth
grade in Madagascar maybe ten percent
complete 12th grade and you you see that
you say that you know most people are
not going to complete 12 grade so
therefore doesn't make any sense to try
to get the bottom of the class to if I
believe a that completely treadwear it
is the only thing that I care about and
B that only a small fraction of this kid
capable of reaching 12 built I think
both of which are probably false but
imagine I believe those two things
how shall I teach I'll teach to the top
of the class and because there's the
only people who are going to make it so
I might as well concentrate my resources
on that and not and forget about the
rest the rest are here as passages
they're like they're going to come
they're going to listen me they won't
get anything they'll leave I don't
really care because that's not the goal
and in particular there's a nice a
instance of this I'll talk about an
experiment in a little bit where the
class was and the school got an extra
teacher let's say for eighth grade and
our fourth grade and in fourth grade
this class was split up and half the
class was given to the extra teacher and
half the class was given to the you know
the original teacher in some of the
schools it was done so that the better
children went to one children the better
performing children went to one teacher
and the worst-performing children go to
the other teacher when this was done by
lottery so there was a lottery and one
teacher got one and the other got the
other the teacher who got the bottom
half the other class was really upset
because they really believe this is
pointless you know they they they they
they thought that this was just why am i
teaching the bottom half of the class
there's no point in teaching them
because they to believe that the bottom
of the class can't learn this their
whole goal is is not to get from them to
from fourth grade to fifth grade but
from to get them to fourth grade to
twelfth grade so the goal of teaching is
pointless to teach people at the bottom
of the class because people at the
bottom of the class can't learn so once
you believe that the bhaktapur bottom of
the class can't learn then you then you
focus your effort at the top of the
class now that as you can imagine what
is the
of that under students what would that
do to students at the bottom of the
class
yeah so discouraged now what happens
when they get discouraged so they work
what does the teacher thing they have
their stupid so he it's a self it's a
vicious cycle because months I believe
the start of this theory that you know
the bottom of the class can't perform
then I give them no attention they're
all dis discouraged they're not trying
they're doing badly I think they're
stupid then I feel like you know I was
right in focusing on the top of the
class so that's you get into this
vicious cycle of of false beliefs
the other thing that this would mean is
that teachers teachers also really so
teachers also in class they will look
for the kids who can get to you know
their view of whatever the goal is
getting through high school and if there
are a few kids like that in high school
in this class then you'll stop putting
in effort so teachers whose also expect
why teachers would not put in a lot of
effort because they'll think look you
know I will go I got stuck with a bunch
of you know yes you know daughters who
can't learn what am I doing here
so once teachers start believing that
children are unequal then you can you
get this phenomenon that lots of
teachers also give up so the pro time
experience is is I think illuminating
here so one of the one of the
experiments you must have talked about
was a summer school experience
experiment the summer school was
basically some villages randomly got a
summer school the teacher was teacher
who was given some extra money to run a
summer school this is the same teacher
who teaches in school and where the
school is you know schools are very
low-performing yet when this teacher was
given a small amount of money and was
the last to run a six weeks summer
school after a few days of training that
had very large effects on the children's
learning the children went to summer
school learned a lot so why is it that
this teacher who can teach these
children quite effectively in summer
school
why doesn't he teach them effectively
during the school year right what's
going on why can't if we sweep how can
it be that this you know when you did
that the same teacher when it is a
summer school he gets a large gains but
when he teaches
when he teaches regular school he does
so badly and one explanation is that in
summer school his job is to attend to
the worst performing children in the
regular school he his perception is that
his job is to attend to the top of the
class so in the regular year his T is
not teaching this children he's teaching
the top of the class when he's actually
told teach these children he actually
can do it just fine
he just that's not what the system is
telling him he's his whole his view of
what his job is is let me I have to get
the top of the class to learn the entire
curriculum and you know be able to get
into whatever into better high school or
something he doesn't see his goal as
teaching the bottom of the class when
you actually ask him to teach the water
over the class that's when is that is a
sign job he just he does just fine so
that would also be consistent with this
view that the real problem is not that
the teachers have don't have the
incentive to teacher they don't want to
teach but they've been told to teach the
wrong thing they're trying to teach
these children some something that's
that actually isn't so here's here's the
experiment I talked about this is very
much on this point I already talked
about this experiment where teach you
know 120 schools where were cut into two
in sixty schools all schools were given
extra teachers okay and then half of
those schools the extra teacher was
assigned to the class was split at
random so every class they used to have
one teacher now they have two teachers
okay class was split at random so half
the class went to one half went to the
other in the other half of the schools
they were not split at random they were
split by baseline competency so they
were
the better children were better
performing children was sent to one
teacher the worst performing children
were sent to the to the other teacher
this was the teacher assigned us was
random so we didn't get a better teacher
or worse teacher but you got a you you
you but you got to be in a classroom
with children like you
what would our theories say about what's
going to happen in such as if you have
aiming at the top what would happen in
this setting yeah
people that are respectively at the top
of the last one they still been talked
to what it means that people exactly so
what this does is I always want to teach
the best for people only in the
classroom but the best people in the
classroom have changed when I when I
divided the classroom in this way the
best people in the low-low classroom is
someone who would have never got any
attention in the in the original
classroom where as or if it was divided
random he would never be at the top so
it changes who gets attention moreover
because I am now paying attention to
somebody who's not at the top of the
class but in the middle of the class the
children who are at the bottom of the
class are more likely to get something
out of the class right because what
happens is that the distance between you
know imagine that you know this is a
class which has me and someone else and
I can't really read and somebody else
can kind of read Shakespeare now if you
teach the top of the class I'll get
nothing but if I put in a classroom with
somebody who can who can read a little
better than me but not that much better
then if you teach to him I'll still get
something out of it because I'm closer
to him is that
yeah therefore you're protesting I said
this before the electric for texting but
once they found out they decided fine
we'll teach the best of this class but
the best of this class is still much
less different from the worst of this
class then the difference between the
best and the worst in the original class
so even the worst in this class gets
something out of the teaching where you
would have got nothing before
that's an excellent question I guess my
view is that it's difficult to get the
teachers to believe what believe that
they should have a different attitude as
long as parents have that attitude so
you need to start with the parents
because after all the demand for
education comes from the parents so the
parents are the ones who who are
demanding this education so in other
words the two to go back to where we
started well in this view what's wrong
with the school system is that the
parents think that you know the oh
there's no point in educating their
children unless the children are good
enough to kind of graduate high school
therefore they want the entire education
system to focus on the few people in the
classroom who are high performing and
ignore the rest if that's what the
parents want the teachers will deliver
that it's going to get too hard to get
them to do anything else you'll first
have to start by persuading parents that
even if their child is not going to get
to high school he still should be
educated I think that's that's that sort
of the ring this
so so in fact that's what exactly what
they found they found that when you do
this when you move when you divide this
class up everybody benefits the top
children benefit because they're now
being taught the teacher is focusing on
them the top children of the bottom
class benefit because the teachers
benefiting from them the bottom children
the top class benefit because they are
now closer to the top of top of their
own classroom and the bottom children in
the bottom class benefit because they
are closer to the top of their classroom
so everybody is better off in this
outcome because if you as long as you
can't force the teachers to teach to the
you know teach the bottom then the what
you can do next best thing is to bring
the bottom closer to the top and this is
what this does if teachers are going to
teach to the top then you try to have
classroom so the bottom is close to the
top and that's what you see the evidence
is very clear everyone benefits from
this creating these tracks
this is the table I won't go through it
because we've been running out of time I
missed this this this is already we said
who else gets hurt by this is the is the
children obviously the children get hurt
because they they get they they they get
they get discouraged most children get
discouraged because they think education
is not for them and this is especially
true in historically discriminated
populations so historically
discriminated populations in many
countries tend to be either the sort of
you know by race or by can Indians by
caste or some other resource of girls
depending on the particular structure
discrimination that historically
discriminated populations tend to
already assume that since they have very
few people who have been educated they
assume that that's perhaps because they
have no talent for it
and then if you go and tell them look
you know so another way to put it is
that if you were if you happen to be
from from a family which believes that
you can be educated then if the teacher
says you're stupid they won't believe it
they're going to go and argue with the
teacher and say look you know well you
know in my family everybody has a PhD
what do what do you mean my son is
stupid whereas if you actually from a
family where no one has an education
it's much easier to persuade them that
you know their their child is not fit
for education so what you're going to do
is you reinforce stereotypes in society
because you're going to who's going to
believe you when you say your child is
stupid it's going to be the people who
who have been told historically that
they are not fit for education they're
going to be the most likely to believe
you
so if wow this kind
stereotype will be read the existing
stereotype will be reinforced by if you
give people the message that you know
that their child is stupid the existing
stereotype would get reinforced so
that's that's something that you see a
lot you see that the parents of of in
these kind of very poor families tend to
be more likely to believe these negative
stereotypes of the children another
thing that this would explain is why
children don't come to school like one
thing that people don't emphasize is how
rarely is children show up in school a
lot lot of a lot of children a lot of
children basically completely don't
believe that school is for them and they
they may be enrolled in school so in a
given day up to 50% of the children
don't show up in a class now that's also
true at MIT it turns out for probably
not for the same reasons but it's it's
it's many of these children basically
hate being in school and the head being
in school for the right reason which is
that they're constantly being told that
this is not for you one interesting
additional fact that was was this goes
back to the stereotype this is a nice
experiment so children were asked to
solve mazes you know what mazes are like
you know these things where you do have
to draw a line and there's a point of
entry and a point of exit and you have
to find your way out of it so they were
given these mazes and asked to solve
I've done this actually it's fun to do
you can take a bunch of sheets and get
you know people in the village to you
know to give them kids and get them to
solve them and it's a very good test of
of cognitive abilities turns out so
that's what people usually do now
somebody the good
idea of trying the following they went
to a village in India and they got
together a group of historically low
caste people people who were
discriminated against and combined them
with people from high caste and put them
in the same group and in one experiment
they just asked them play the maze do
the maze and I found no difference
between high caste and locals they got
exactly the same score same scores not
everybody didn't get the same score
obviously but on average there was no
difference second experiment before the
play the game everybody was asked their
caste
so caste was made salient and
immediately you see a big difference you
see that the people who are historically
discriminated self discriminate they
start playing badly they believe that
they can't compete with the other guys
and they they do much worse so once you
make car salient so it's exactly this
fact that once you prime my belief that
I have I already am unsure whether I can
do these things you prime my belief that
I am from a particular caste I'm playing
against these guys from a superior caste
I'm just going to think I'm going to
lose and it's very simple you know you
just have to get them to remember what
their caste is and there's another
experiment which is also interesting
I'll just say that and then in another
experiment teachers were asked to grade
the same paper and in some some some
they were told that the paper was from a
high caste person and some they were
told that the the same paper was from a
low caste person same paper exact same
paper photocopy of the same thing with
the same answers but you asked to grade
it and in one case I said this is from
cast a the other case I say so Cosby
that was the experiment
then the teacher teaches themselves some
of the high caste sound her low caste
who do you think discriminated what was
the pattern or risk
turns out the opposite the low pass this
to me the locust locust we're scoring
their own cost people Lord because they
also believe that they they dealt you
know people of the cast cannot do it
everybody so you have this underlying
stereotype and now you prime that by
saying you know this kid is stupid you
know what are they going to do they just
give up very quickly because they
already believe that they are not really
capable of doing it yeah
I think the lame doctor fighter am i
right
they waited up with the others went down
no no discrimination by the high card
only the low caste great
no the zero they affect only the
features displayed against of nope a
students
that was the it was dramatically it's
not what I expected but it tells shows
the self discrimination is very powerful
reason I emphasize that is that that's
the problem here right one size to have
a classroom full of kids who who are
being told they're stupid
the ones who who are from a high caste
are going to say look you know I know my
grandfather was a whatever a religious
teacher and my father's a religious
teacher I know I'm fit for education I'm
going to continue it's the people who
have weak self belief were going to be
hurt by a system which basically
discriminates against them